.
Es war nicht Liebe
auf den ersten Blick,
aber ich war sehr fasziniert.
Obwohl wir
nicht dieselbe Sprache sprechen,
haben wir uns
extrem gut verstanden - nonverbal.
Es war bald einmal ersichtlich,
dass es einen Einfluss
auf mein Leben haben wird.
* Romantische Musik *
# Take my hand, take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be
forever you and me.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Herzschläge *
* Wellenrauschen *
(Eine Liebe, die Grenzen überwindet,
kann einen an Orte bringen, die man
sich nie hätte träumen lassen.)
(So wie Nicole und Rachid Dohi
auf Sansibar.)
Wer ist von euch
die grösste Wasserratte?
Vermutlich ich.
Ich bin ausgebildete Divemaster.
Sicher? Ehrlich?
- Ja
(Nicole kommt aus der Schweiz,
ihr Mann Rachid aus Marokko.)
(Mit ihrer Tochter Lila
führen sie seit zwei Jahren
in Sansibar ein Hotel.)
* Fröhliche,
gezupfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Trotz Nicoles Liebe zum Wasser
sind solche Familienausflüge selten.)
(Das Hotel nimmt beide in Beschlag.)
Wir müssen uns aufteilen.
Bin ich weg, muss er da sein
und umgekehrt.
Entweder habe ich Lila an dem Tag
oder er.
Es ist eine Challenge.
Habt ihr das gewusst?
Der Preis, hierherzukommen,
geht auf Kosten des Familienlebens.
Es war vorher schon so.
Er war Polizeiinspektor,
arbeitete auf Abruf
und hatte auch Nachtdienst.
So viel hat sich nicht geändert -
ausser dass wir
für das Gleiche arbeiten.  - Ja.
Bei meiner Arbeit
war es wirklich zu viel -
manchmal bis zu 16 Std. pro Tag.
Auch hier arbeite ich viel -
von morgens früh bis abends,
wenn ich abschliesse.
Das zwingt mich manchmal,
darüber nachzudenken,
was ich hier überhaupt mache.
Es ist genau das Gleiche.
Ich habe gekündigt, Freunde und
Familie in Marokko zurückgelassen.
Aber das hier hattest du nicht.
Das war für dich ein grosses Opfer?
Für Nicole ist das hier der Traum.
Am Strand zu leben
und ein Hotel zu führen.
Für dich nicht?
- Nein, mein Traum war das nicht.
Aber wir hatten einen Deal,
Monsieur.
* Rachid lacht. *
Wir hatten einen Deal.
Ich sagte: "Ich will das machen."
Er sagte: "Ich will eine Familie."
Nein, nein, nein.
Das kann ich so nicht akzeptieren.
Non, non, non.
Und zuerst kam Lila.
* Rachid lacht. *
Achtung,
ich verstehe Schweizerdeutsch.
Zuerst kam Lila
und ein paar Jahre später
hatten wir endlich den Strand.
(Da gibt es offenbar noch
ein wenig Interpretationsspielraum.)
Wäh!
(Klar ist aber,
die Familie ist mit Lila komplett.)
(Einen Strand haben sie auch,
inkl. einem tropischen Aquarium,
das einlädt abzutauchen und
allfällige Misstöne zu vergessen.)
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
* Herzschlag *
Natürlich war ich sehr nervös,
als ich dich damals
am Flughafen abgeholt habe.
Wir dachten: "Oh mein Gott,
wir haben nun das gleiche
Hotelzimmer für drei Tage."
"Was ist, wenn es nichts klappt?"
"Was ist, wenn wir uns
miserabel fühlen
und am liebsten sofort wieder
nach Hause gehen würden?"
Wir entschieden uns dafür,
es locker zu nehmen
und einfach die Tage zu geniessen.
Wir verabredeten auch, dass wir,
wenn wir uns am Flughafen sehen,
mal gar nichts sagen würden
bis zum Mittagessen.
Und erst beim Mittagessen sprachen
wir darüber, wie wir uns fühlen.
Genau so machten
wir es dann.
Yes, so we did.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Nur diese Flaggen und ein paar Fotos
erinnern bei Florence zu Hause
in Derendingen an Niklas.)
(Sie wohnt hier
zusammen mit ihrer Tochter Noya
und mit sage und schreibe
sieben Hunden.)
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Etwa alle zwei Monate reist Florence
für ein verlängertes Wochenende
zu ihrem Mann nach Schweden.)
(Der Abschied fällt, auch wenn es
nur für ein paar Tage ist, schwer,
auch den Hunden.)
Sie ist eines unser Sensibelchen.
Sie mag es nicht,
wenn ich nicht da bin.
Aber mit der Oma klappt es gut.
* Sie lacht. *
Hauptsache, sie hat ihr Spielzeug.
Sorgen macht man sich wohl immer.
Die ganze Hundeschar
ist so etwas wie meine Babys.
Und wenn man sie immer ...
Lässt man sie ab und zu alleine,
vermisst man sich auch.
* Kläffen *
(Aber zum Glück hat Florence Hilfe.)
* Aufgeregtes Bellen *
Meine Mutter kommt gleich.
Während ich weg bin,
wohnt sie auch hier.
Sie kümmert sich um die Hunde,
geht mit ihnen raus, füttert sie
und sie schläft auch hier.
Für die Hunde
ist das so die perfekte Lösung.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Zudem hat meine Tochter
einen vollen Kühlschrank.
Meine Mutter kocht natürlich für sie
und ist hier mit ihr,
weil sie nicht alleine bleiben kann.
Das ist für mich ...
... eine super Lösung
und ich bin auch sehr dankbar dafür.
Warte, ich muss Nora wegnehmen.
* Kläffen *
Warte! Die Oma kommt gleich.
(Leise) Warte!
* Zauberhafte Klänge,
aufgeregtes Bellen *
* Jaulen *
Nein, nein, nein!
So! Jetzt wird gewartet.
Ich verpasse wegen euch
noch meinen Flug.
Nora, komm! He!
So, fertig jetzt!
* Zauberhafte Klänge,
aufgeregtes Bellen *
Jetzt wird gewartet.
* Drollige Akkorde *
* Drollige Musik *
(Und dann klappt es doch noch.)
(Endlich ab zum Flughafen.)
* Lockere Musik *
(Jönköping -
eine Stadt in Südschweden.)
(Da betreibt Niklas zusammen mit
seinem Bruder Adam eine Glaserei.)
(Die beiden starteten erst kürzlich
mit dem Betrieb.)
(Sie sind daran,
sich eine Kundschaft aufzubauen.)
(Leben und arbeiten in Schweden,
auch wenn er mit einer Frau
in der Schweiz verheiratet ist.)
Wir starteten vor einem Jahr
und sind seither gut ausgebucht.
It's very nice.
Ich dachte nie daran, aber wenn ich
in der Schweiz leben würde,
bräuchte ich eine Arbeit.
Das hier ist mein Job
und genau das müsste ich
auch wieder machen können.
Das ist das, was ich kann.
So, jetzt gibt's ein Barbecue.
The Barbecue is about to heat the
plastic that is between the glasses.
Ich führte auch ein Reisebüro,
wo ich Trekkings
in der ganzen Welt organisierte -
in Peru, Nepal und Tansania.
Ich habe auch überlegt,
dieses Geschäft auszubauen
und ein bisschen mehr zu klettern.
Aber dann habe ich
Florence getroffen
und die Sache hat sich geändert.
Jetzt möchte ich nicht mehr irgendwo
in der Welt herumreisen.
* Sanfte, perlende Klänge *
(Planänderung also.)
(Ein Glasergeschäft in Jönköping
statt Bergsteigen im Himalaya.)
(Das alles der Liebe wegen.)
(Und die ist schon im Anflug.)
* Entspannte Musik *
(Wie immer, wenn Niklas Florence
am Flughafen Göteborg abholt,
gibt es einen Blumenstrauss.)
Last-Minute-Blumen, eigentlich
möchte ich eine einzelne Rose.
Ich bin nicht nervös,
ich freue mich einfach.
Die sind schön, oder?
* Flughafendurchsage, Stimmengewirr *
Hu, hu, hu, la, la.
Da kommt sie.
* Gefühlvolle Musik *
Du siehst super aus.
Hattest du eine gute Reise?
You take this, you take this.
Entschuldige meine Aufmachung,
ich war an der Arbeit.
* Herzschlag *
Er ist der Mann, den ich mir
immer vorgestellt habe.
Ein richtiger Mann!
Er ist gross, er ist gescheit, er
ist kräftig, er ist selbstbewusst.
Er ist gebildet.
Nein, es ist klar.
* Schwungvolle Trommelmusik *
(Das Hotel am Strand von Sansibar
war nicht nur Nicoles Idee,
sie hat es auch selbst mitaufgebaut.)
Wenn du siehst, wie es jetzt ist:
Mit welchen Gefühlen
läufst du da täglich herum?
Manchmal muss man sich schon sagen:
"Mein Gott! Du hast das gemacht."
Ja, ja, stolz.
Es finden es alle toll, klar.
Aber dass wirklich ich es war,
die mitgeholfen hat
beim Buddeln,
Graben und Streichen und ...
Dessen sind sie sich nicht bewusst.
Wünschst du dir
etwas mehr Anerkennung?
Z.B. Rachid -
sieht er, weiss er, was du ...
Ja, aber er hat sich während
des Bauens völlig ausklinkt,
das war nicht sein Ding.
- Ja.
Er hat zu sich geschaut,
er musste sich finden.
Er ging ins Fitness und all das.
Ich schuftete.
Irgendwann habe ich es angenommen,
es interessierte ihn nicht,
er wollte es nicht -
darum machte ich es. So.
Was macht das mit der Beziehung?
Ihr seid euch nicht näher gekommen.
Nein, am Anfang
war es recht schwierig.
Er war sehr unzufrieden.
Es sei nicht seins,
er sei nicht der Strandtyp.
Er fand, in Marokko sei alles
einfacher, was vielleicht stimmt,
denn wir sind in Schwarz-
und nicht in Nordafrika.
Dort ist alles
viel weiterentwickelt.
Ich sagte dann,
wir müssten das durchziehen.
"Wir eröffnen und wenn es das
nicht ist, können wir wieder gehen."
Wenn ich meinen Auftrag quasi
erfüllt, das Ding aufgestellt habe,
dann kann ich auch loslassen.
Das hast du ihm gesagt? - Ja,
aber er musste sagen, wohin ...
Ja.
- ... und was wir dann machen.
(Zwei Lebensentwürfe
unter einen Hut zu bringen,
ist auch im vermeintlichen Paradies
nicht einfach.)
(Rachid, ehemaliger Polizeiinspektor
aus Essaouira in Marokko,
brauchte einen Moment, um sich mit
den neuen Umständen anzufreunden.)
* Lockere Musik *
Das ist ein neues Kapitel
in meinem Leben.
Jetzt bin ich zufrieden und -
das ist mein Naturell -
ich bin immer neugierig zu sehen,
wie sich das alles entwickeln wird.
Es ist ein Kraftakt:
auswandern und das alte Leben
in der Heimat zurücklassen.
Rachid machte es seiner Frau zuliebe.
* Monotoner Klang *
* Die Musik
übertönt das Gesprochene. *
Das war nicht dein Traum,
sondern jener von Nicole.
Warum hast du dich
trotzdem entschieden,
hier ein neues Leben anzufangen?
Erstens wollte ich sowieso
aus dem Polizeidienst aussteigen.
Zweitens bin ich jemand,
der nicht allzu lange nachdenkt
vor einer Entscheidung.
Si je vais reflechir trop,
peut-etre je vais dire non.
Und drittens wusste ich,
dass Nicole eine starke Frau ist,
die mir auch helfen würde,
die ersten Schritte zu machen.
* Wellenrauschen,
Stimmen im Hintergrund *
* Windrauschen *
(Nicole fiel die Umstellung
leichter als ihrem Mann.)
(Als Geschäftsführerin des Hotels hat
sie eine klar definierte Aufgabe,
die sie mit viel Power anpackt.)
(Heute Abend nimmt sie mich mit
an eine sog. Ladies Night,
an ein Treffen von Businessfrauen.)
Es ist ein geschäftlicher Ausgang
für alle.
Aha, das ist ...
Du als Geschäftsfrau
bist am Netzwerken?
Es sind alles Geschäftsfrauen.
Sie sind es,
die hier ein bisschen Gas geben.
(Rachid erhielt von den Behörden
lange keine Aufenthaltsbewilligung.)
(Deshalb konnte er nicht richtig
ins Geschäft einsteigen.)
Wie war das für ihn?
- V.a. für ihn war es sehr blöd.
Für sie war er quasi nichts -
und er war auch nicht willkommen.
Das nagt ein wenig
am Selbstbewusstsein.
Gerade bei einem arabischen Macho.
Polizeiinspektor.
Ich finde, bei ihm
merkt man das überhaupt nicht.
Gott sei Dank, sonst hätte ich ihn
nicht geheiratet.
Er trug auch keine Uniform. Er war
undercover unterwegs, trug Jeans.
Ich wusste lange nicht,
was er macht.
Er war immer auf der Strasse,
sass in einem Cafe.
Er musste Drogendealer aufspüren.
Kriminelle.
Ich hielt ihn für einen interes-
santen Typen, der aber nichts tat.
Bis wir herausfanden ...
- ... dass er trotzdem etwas macht.
Bei euch war es so: Du hattest
einen Traum und er kam mit.
Du bist die Chefin und er kommt mit.
Und wir sind nicht im selben Land,
weder in meinem noch in seinem.
In einem eigenen Land.
Wir sind seit zwölf Jahren zusammen.
Und wir sind nicht mehr
so Feuer und Flamme füreinander.
Ich glaube,
wir repräsentieren ein bisschen ...
Nach zehn Ehejahren
geht es den meisten so.
Es verflattert einfach ein bisschen.
Ich glaube schon,
dass wir uns noch lieben.
Sagen wir mal, wir sind eine super
gut funktionierende Familie. - Ja.
(Romantisch klingt das
vermutlich nicht, aber ehrlich.)
(Ich spüre, dass Nicole und Rachid
auch ohne Schmetterlinge im Bauch
durch ein starkes Band
verbunden sind.)
* Stimmengewirr *
Zum Wohl, freut mich sehr.
Nicole, zum Wohl.
* Herzschlag *
Ich glaube,
du hast selber vorgeschlagen,
dass du nach Schweden kommen wirst,
wenn wir zusammenziehen.
Für mich war das super.
"Bist du sicher?"
"Ja." Keine Diskussion, perfekt!
Bei der Jobsuche
hatte ich auch das Gefühl,
in Schweden
schneller etwas zu finden,
dass Leute in meinem Gebiet
eher gesucht sind.
Das war eigentlich
bald einmal ein Thema.
Und natürlich auch die Option,
dass Land und Eigentum
hier in Schweden
erschwinglicher ist
als in der Schweiz.
Man hat auch in Schweden die
Möglichkeit, irgendwo zu leben,
wo man alleine ist.
Das half uns,
zusammen weiterzumachen.
Hättest du gesagt,
du würdest dein Land nie verlassen
und ich hätte das Gleiche gesagt,
hätten wir
ein grosses Problem gehabt.
Wahrscheinlich hätten wir uns
Tschüss sagen müssen.
(Bekanntlich kam es anders.)
(So hat sich im hin- und herpendeln
zwischen Derendingen und Jönköping
eine Art Routine eingestellt.)
Hallo!
Hey!
Hoi, Bubeli.
Ja, hoi.
He missed you.
Ja, ja, ja.
(Auch da muss Florence
nicht auf Hundeliebe verzichten.)
Das sind Geschenke
von Florences' Mutter.
Das auch.
Das ist von Florence.
Und das habe ich an einer Party
in der Schweiz geklaut.
Ah, du hast die Schokolade gefunden.
- Ja.
Was ich nicht mag,
habe ich dir übriggelassen.
Ich fühle mich nicht als Single,
auch wenn wir uns
fünf oder sechs Wochen nicht sehen.
Wir sprechen jeden Tag zusammen.
Wir beenden den Tag gemeinsam,
auch aus der Distanz.
Wir wissen,
was beim anderen passiert.
Ich fühle mich ihr nah.
Ich weiss, wie ihre Tage aussehen,
und sie kennt meine.
Wenn ich in der Schweiz bin,
bin ich in meinem Tagestrott.
Man läuft und funktioniert.
Ja, dann ist Schweden
wieder etwas weit weg.
Wenn ich hier oben bin,
kann ich die Verantwortung
zu Hause an meine Mutter abgeben.
Dann kann ich hier abschalten.
Und dann bin ich auch zu 100 % hier.
Das ergibt dann jeweils ...
Da ist dieser Konflikt,
wenn ich nach Hause fliege
oder wenn ich hierherfliege.
Manchmal braucht es einen Tag,
manchmal sind es mehrere Tage,
bis ich im Alltag
wieder funktioniere.
Es ist nicht immer ganz einfach.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Die zwei kennen sich
seit zwei Jahren.)
(Letzten Juni heirateten sie.)
(Florence ist in Jönköping
schon etwas heimisch geworden.)
(Dabei halfen auch Niklas' Freunde.)
* Stimmengewirr *
Das sind natürlich Freunde
von seiner Seite.
Aber ich habe mich eigentlich ab dem
ersten Augenblick an wohlgefühlt.
Sie sind sehr sympathisch.
Wir treffen uns auch regelmässig.
Eigentlich immer, wenn ich hier bin.
Und, ähm ...
Ich fühle mich sehr aufgehoben.
* Sie spricht schwedisch. *
Ah, vegeterian.
- Very vegetarian.
* Lachen *
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge,
Stimmengewirr *
* Herzpochen *
Als ich ihn das erste Mal sah ...
Ich wollte mich
nicht unbedingt treffen.
Meine Freundin kannte ihn schon und
sagte, ich solle nicht rumzicken.
Ich sollte mich treffen
und dann sei es ja egal.
Ich sagte: "Okay."
Ich war mega stur.
Ich trug eine graue Hose
und die Schuhe, die ich jetzt trage.
Ich öffnete die Türe: "Ui!" Ich
machte die Türe gleich wieder zu.
Ich trug ein bisschen Make-up auf.
Dann machte ich die Türe auf: "Yes?"
* Rhythmische Musik *
(14 Jahre ist es her, seit Kub zum
ersten Mal vor Claudias Türe stand.)
(Seitdem ist die Zürcherin mit
dem NBA-Basketballprofi zusammen.)
(Lange lebten sie in Miami,
weil Kub bei den Miami Heat
einen Vertrag hatte.)
(Hierhin zieht es Claudia
immer noch oft,
nun aber für ihr eigenes Geschäft.)
(Sie ist
ins Catering-Business eingestiegen.)
* Zarte Gitarrenklänge *
In Miami ist es immer schön warm.
Die Leute sind eigentlich nett.
Fürs Business ist es sehr gut,
weil es viele Athleten gibt,
viele andere Superstars,
die singen oder rappen,
die sich einen Privatkoch
leisten wollen.
Mega cool, all diese herbs.
Look at the basil.
(Claudia kam ursprünglich
nicht wegen der Liebe in die USA.)
(Sie war Zirkusartistin und Tänzerin
und baute sich in den Vereinigten
Staaten eine Karriere auf,
bis am Valentinstag
ein grosser Mann in ihr Leben trat.)
Ein guter Tag. An diesem Tag haben
Kub und ich uns erstmals getroffen.
Sozusagen per Zufall.
In Amerika
ist das ein grosses Thema.
Alle hatten einen Valentine
und ich war alleine zu Hause
in Los Angeles.
Dann hat Kub
mir wieder einmal geschrieben.
Er hat mir immer
via Myspace geschrieben.
Er hat immer gesagt, als er mich
gesehen habe, habe er gewusst,
dass er mich heiraten wollte,
obwohl wir uns nicht kannten.
Er schrieb mich immer wieder an
und ich schrieb nie zurück.
Ich dachte: "Nein, nein,
so ein grosser, dunkler Mann."
"Lieber nicht."
Und irgendwann habe ich nachgegeben,
zufällig am Valentinstag.
(Ein folgenschwerer Zufall.)
(Die beiden sind
seit über zehn Jahren verheiratet
und haben zwei Töchter.)
Hey!
Schau, wo ich bin.
Happy Valentine's Day!
Alright,
talk to you later, love you.
Bye.
Ich habe mich einfach
in seine Art verliebt.
Er ist einfach so ...
Seine Augen, sein Wesen.
Wie er ist - so ruhig.
Er ist das totale Gegenteil von mir.
Er nimmt es eher gelassen,
ich bin eher zackiger, schneller.
Wenn ich mit der Tür ins Haus falle,
ist er sehr relaxed.
* Rhythmische Klaviermusik *
(Kub, eigentlich Yakhouba Diawara,
ist Basketballprofi.)
(Einer, der es geschafft hat.)
(Aus Frankreich führte ihn
seine Karriere über Italien
bis in die amerikanische NBA,
die beste Liga der Welt.)
(Jetzt, gegen Ende
seiner aktiven Karriere,
könnte noch eine neue Herausforderung
auf ihn warten.)
(Ein Abstecher nach Afrika.)
Es wäre das erste Mal, dass
die NBA nach Afrika gehen würde.
Ich bin sehr aufgeregt,
auch meine Freunde aus Senegal,
wo meine Familie
ursprünglich herkommt.
Ich kann es kaum erwarten,
den Leuten etwas zurückzugeben.
(Hier in New York
findet so etwas wie ein Casting
für die Mannschaft statt.)
(Eine Chance,
die Kub unbedingt packen will.)
Ich bin in Frankreich aufgewachsen,
meine Frau ist aus der Schweiz
und meine Kinder
sind in den USA geboren -
wir sind also total gemischt.
Deshalb interessiert mich Afrika,
ein weiterer Kontinent.
Je mehr man sieht,
verschiedene Kulturen,
offen sein gegenüber anderem,
das ist das Beste.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass Basketball mir das ermöglicht.
Ich kann mich wirklich
glücklich schätzen.
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
(Wie so oft,
ist Yakhouba alleine unterwegs,
weg von seiner Frau Claudia
und seinen beiden Töchtern.)
Hi, Minou!
- Hey, how are you?
Hallo! Ich traf den Präsidenten
der afrikanischen Basketballliga.
Er sah meinen Namen und wusste
nicht, dass ich wirklich hier bin:
"Kuba, bist du es wirklich?"
"So schön, dass du da bist!"
So weit, so gut.
Alles geht bestens und wir haben
Spass. Mal sehen, was passiert.
Okay.
Wie geht's mit dem Kochen?
Ich habe gerade
einen Fisch für 280 $ gekauft.
Oh, ein toller Fisch.
* Claudia lacht. *
Alright.
- Alright. Bye.
Sie kocht.
(Basketball hat das Leben von Ya-
khouba völlig auf den Kopf gestellt.)
(Als Sohn
senegalesischer Einwanderer
ist er in Paris in einfachen
Verhältnissen aufgewachsen.)
(Geldsorgen
sind heute kein Thema mehr.)
(Aber auch das Leben eines Superstars
hat Nachteile.)
Das Blöde ist, man ist immer weg,
hat Zeitverschiebung.
Facetime und Skype sind schon gut,
aber natürlich nicht das Gleiche.
Aber eben, wir haben
dieses Leben selber gewählt.
Uns hat niemand gezwungen.
Wir wussten beide,
worauf wir uns einlassen.
* Herzpochen *
Alles hängt zusammen.
Die ganze Verantwortung.
Die Liebe bleibt natürlich,
aber sie mischt sich
mit der Verantwortung,
den Problemen, der Freude,
der Arbeit.
Auch mit dem Erfolg des Hotels.
Die Beziehung
wird immer vielschichtiger.
Wir sind erwachsene Menschen.
Es gibt Augenblicke der Liebe
und der Freude,
aber es gibt neben den Höhen
auch Tiefen.
Das ist einfach so.
* Lockere Musik *
(Alltag auf Sansibar.)
(Gut eine Million Menschen leben
hier, praktisch alles Moslems.)
(Viele leben vom Tourismus, dem
wichtigsten Wirtschaftszweig hier.)
(Zu Rachids Aufgaben
gehört das Einkaufen.)
Salem Aleikum.
(Die meisten reden Swahili,
mit Arabisch oder Englisch
kommt man auch durch.)
Honey, one box.
Marsala, Cinnamon.
- Okay.
* Sie sprechen englisch. *
* Lockere Musik *
(Nicole ist unterwegs
in die Hauptstadt,
etwa 1 Std.
von ihrem Hotel entfernt.)
Ich kaufe mir immer eine Kokosnuss,
wenn ich in der Stadt ankomme.
Das ist das Beste,
besser als Wasser.
Eine ist für den Chauffeur.
Ich habe nie Heimweh.
Es gibt zwei, drei Dinge,
die mir manchmal fehlen.
Das ist - logisch -
die Familie, Freunde.
Die Aare, die gute Aare in Bern.
Ja.
Und das Kino.
Hello!
Ich brauche Schuhe
für die Leute in der Küche.
Und zwar ziemlich viele.
Can you show me?
Sie haben die normalen Crocs?
Auch hier gibt es Hygienekontrollen.
Würden sie in ihren Latschen kochen,
hätte ich ein Problem -
mit dem Staat,
wenn sie kontrollieren würden.
Okay, wie viel kostet das?
- 66.
Auch wenn ich zwölf Stück nehme,
kosten sie 66?
Before, it was 70.
Geben Sie mir 10 %? 63?
Yes, please, ask him.
63.
(Leise) Bitte, bitte.
Das habe ich in Marokko gelernt.
Schweizer können das nicht
oder machen es nicht gern.
Ich finde das spassig,
das ist ein Sport.
189 - all together.
(Obwohl sie eng zusammenarbeiten,
haben Nicole und Rachid
auch ihre Freiräume.)
(Das Leben in Sansibar unterscheidet
sich fundamental von dem,
was sie sich gewohnt sind - nicht
nur, weil sie ein Hotel führen.)
Es ist nicht sein Zuhause,
es ist nicht mein Zuhause.
Je nachdem ist es positiv
oder negativ - für beide.
Es ist nicht ...
Man kann nicht sagen: "Es ist so,
weil wir nicht zu Hause sind."
Wir haben uns ein gemeinsames
neues Zuhause gesucht, sozusagen.
Das ist für beide eine Challenge.
Keiner hat hier ein Heimspiel.
Keiner hat einen Vorteil,
aber auch keinen Nachteil.
Das ist ... gar nicht so schlecht.
* Rhythmische Trommelmusik *
Ich habe damals das Tanzen und
Singen aufgegeben, den Zirkus -
sozusagen eigentlich alles, was
ich war, um Spielerfrau zu werden.
Oder Spielergirlfriend
oder was auch immer sie sagen.
Eigentlich mein ganzes Leben,
das ich kannte.
(Claudia war auf dem Weg,
Zirkusartistin zu werden.)
(Sie hat für Stars
wie Destiny's Child oder Jay-Z
in Musikvideos getanzt und gesungen.)
(Bis zu dem Moment,
in dem Kub in ihr Leben trat.)
Ich nehme sie für die Kinder
zum Basteln mit.
* Sie lacht. *
Ah! Kalt!
(Claudia ist in Sri Lanka geboren
und als Baby von Schweizer Eltern
adoptiert worden.)
Der Zirkus hat mich
immer mega fasziniert.
Der Circus Knie war der einzige Ort,
an dem ich Menschen sah,
die auch etwas dunkelhäutiger waren
wie ich und nicht weiss.
Es störte mich nicht,
aber ich war fasziniert.
Schon als kleines Kind wusste ich,
dass ich dorthin musste,
um sie zu sehen
und mit ihnen reden zu können.
(Und das schaffte sie auch.)
(Sogar weit über den Knie hinaus,
bis in den Cirque du Soleil.
Hoi!
They're puppies?
- Ten weeks old yesterday.
Ten weeks.
Hoi, ja, ja.
(Was sie mit dem NBA-Spieler
an Land gezogen hatte,
sei ihr nicht bewusst gewesen.)
Ich kannte Basketball nicht.
Professionelle Spieler, Athleten -
das Business kannte ich nicht.
Ich habe das gar nicht ...
Ich habe auch geturnt, ich war im
Zirkus, er spielt halt Basketball.
Ich wusste überhaupt nicht,
worauf ich mich da einlasse.
(Plötzlich war Kub
nicht einfach ihr neuer Freund,
sie hat auch
einen richtigen Job übernommen.)
Über eine Spielerfrau denken alle,
es sei schön,
wir würden nur shoppen.
Schöne Kleider und Täschchen
und Chanel und Gucci.
Aber es ist gar nicht so.
80 % eines Athleten ...
Als Frau eines Athleten
hat man es sehr streng.
Man muss schauen, dass er gut isst,
dass er ausgeschlafen ist.
Man darf vor einem Spiel
nicht streiten.
Man muss immer nett sein,
man muss sich zurückziehen.
Es ist recht kompliziert.
Das ganze Leben
dreht sich nur um ihn.
Alles muss um ihn angepasst werden.
Bei einer so grossen Persönlichkeit
verliert man quasi seine Identität.
* Sanfter Popsong:
"Meant To Be" von Bebe Rexha" *
# Baby, lay on back and relax,
kick your pretty feet up on my dash.
# No need to go nowhere fast,
let's enjoy right here where we are.
# If it's meant to be,
it'll be, it'll be.
# Baby, if it's meant to be.
Eigentlich sollte man
nach sieben bis zehn Jahren ...
Immer nach dieser Periode
sollte man entweder die Ortschaft,
den Beruf oder den Partner wechseln.
Das hält einen einfach fit,
das ist so.
Partner hatten wir vorher
oft gewechselt.
Den Beruf habe ich
mind. dreimal gewechselt.
Jetzt machen wir es halt
mit der Ortschaft.
(Zur Ruhe kommen ist offensichtlich
nicht das Ziel von Nicole.)
* Beschwingte Trommelmusik *
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
So in vier, fünf Jahren
ziehen wir weiter.
V.a. auch wegen der Schule für Lila.
Ihr werdet hier nicht pensioniert?
- Nein.
Der nächste Ort, wie meinst du das?
I don't know.
Dort, wo es für Lila
eine gute Schule gibt.
Das ist kein Problem für mich.
Aber nochmals das Gleiche wie hier
möchte ich nicht mehr.
Ca je ne veux pas le faire.
Qu'est-ce que tu ...
Ich möchte am liebsten nach Marokko,
oder wenigstens in die Nähe.
Nicht mehr
13, 14 Flugstunden entfernt.
Es ist nicht einfach
mit meiner Familie, meiner Mutter,
den Schwestern.
Sie fehlen dir.
Ce n'est pas qu'eux me manquent ...
Unsere Kultur ist einfach anders,
wir sind sehr familienverbunden.
Mein Vater ist gestorben.
Ich möchte
mich um meine Mutter kümmern.
Das gibt's in Europa nicht so.
Das verstehe ich gut.
Du wahrscheinlich auch.
Er möchte bei der Familie sein.
Kannst du dir vorstellen, noch einmal
nach Nordafrika zu ziehen?
Nein, aber in die Richtung
wird es schon gehen,
aber nicht an einen Ort,
an dem ich schon war.
Nein.
Es kann etwas sein,
das weniger weit ist.
Klar, Griechenland.
Warum nicht? Weisst du, so etwas.
Also Richtung Europa ...
ist schon eine Lösung, ja.
D.h., in spätestens vier Jahren
müsst ihr miteinander diskutieren
und einen Kompromiss finden.
Ich denke, es kommt auf uns zu.
Nur nicht suchen.
Wir dürfen nicht suchen,
es wird sich ergeben.
So war es auch mit Sansibar.
So ist das Leben.
Europa ist kein Problem.
* Sanfte, perlende Klänge *
(Ich zweifle keinen Moment,
dass Nicole und Rachid
noch viele spannende Projekte vor
sich haben - und viele Diskussionen.)
(Ohne die geht es nicht in einer Be-
ziehung mit verschiedenen Kulturen.)
(Kompromisse machen
und verzichten können
ist der Preis für das Glück
des Zusammenseins.)
* Sanfte Musik, Plätschern *
* Herzschläge *
"Hin und weg" - nächste Woche
einer der raren Momente,
in denen die ganze Familie Diawara
zusammen ist.
Die Gefahr des Auseinanderlebens
ist da, manchmal geschieht es auch.
In Schweden gibt Niklas alles.
Hier wird es
eine Badewanne für Hunde geben.
Das gibt eine Hundedusche.
Darum liebt sie mich.
Wir haben den Flug umgebucht,
eine Woche eher.
Wir merkten, dass es nicht reicht,
wir wären nicht mehr
aus der Schweiz gekommen.
(In der Schweiz zwingt das
Coronavirus Martina und Cahil
zu einer überstürzten Auswanderung.)
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2020
# Together we will be,
forever you and me. Take my hand.
* Herzschläge *